اكتشاف حاله واحده مصابه او مثبته بمرض
الكوليرا تعني حدوث وبعض
[موسيقى]
قلك انا المنحنى متسطح اي ما في ازدياد
هائل بالاصابات
في عندنا حالات
كثيره عم بتراجع المشافي في حالات اسهال
ولكن
بعد التشخيص
لا يتم اثباته
عندنا تقريبا بحدود 46 وفاه نتيجه التاخر
بطلب المشوره الطبيه
[موسيقى]
فبلش بالصيف في منطقه الفرات لانه صار في
شحبي بياه النار كثير من الناس بمفردات
للبرازيه والبوليه
ماشي الحال
بسبب حراره الطقس
بالعالم فبالتالي صار في ترسل بهذه
الجراثيم وانت شايف والجرس محمول الى
الاطعمه او المسقيه بها المياه فبالتالي
ادى هذا الاشاره بين الناس
[موسيقى]
في مخلفات الحرب والعقوبات الاقتصاديه
سيلجا بعض الناس
شلون صحتك
[موسيقى]